hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play Octodad now
believe it or not I found this game
through a gift that I saw of an octopus
in a suit waking up out of bed and
walking across the room so I knew that I
had to play it once I saw it so I don't
really know what I'm getting myself into
but from the looks of that video it's
gotta be awesome ok wake up dear today
is a huge day you need to hurry dear oh
boy ok hands mode move the mouse to move
the arm and deed to move the camera
while holding the right mouse button or
ctrl left move the mouse forward and
back we'll raise and lower the arm whoa
as complicated instructions when an
object is highlighted green pressing and
holding the left mouse button will move
your arm to grab it press spacebar or
the middle Mouse to switch modes feet
mode Oh God hold the left mouse button
to raise the left foot and the right to
raise the right foot when the foot is
raised moving the mouse will move the
foot oh lordy ok alright so I should be
in feet mode room table table is
actually more more intuitive than I
thought it'd be how do I move the camera
I don't recall oh yeah that's right
indeed to move the camera hello
Lorrimer amir oh wow hahahaha oh man
there redonkulous is okay let's go to
hand mode here
and let's see raise it rabbit I don't
even know what this is
so oh it's highlighted green I can grab
it squirting ink all over the place but
I got whatever the hell this is I don't
think this was part of my objective but
good for me is that a suspicion how
people might get such Oh oh my people
might get suspicious saliva Lauren
octopus all better or not walk to the
alarm clock okay this is the most
ridiculous thing I've ever seen
but it's so damn awesome blows finger oh
I've got a flare Carla give it a flower
no time to go about my day I guess I
don't know what the big the big oh god
camera camera camera grandma grandma
grandma okay thank you I don't know what
the big deal is the first place and why
oh I gotta open the door I'm guessing oh
my oh my
okay so just let's turn around okay
we're facing the wrong direction but
that's okay there we go okay raise it up
move it forward raise it down get that
door yeah that door come on
I gotta get out of here it's my big day
or something I don't know
how do I have a wife I mean I guess if
she was in a Japanese anime she'd be
very very pleased but come on this is
just strange okay come on now come on
now
what do both okay this is not working
out so well so let me just um I have an
objective menu maybe oh look it's all my
pictures it's my uh it's my wedding
pictures actually that's pretty weird
perfectly normal though every living
creature is entitled to a happy life or
something doing the splits here
okay I still don't know what I'm
supposed to do I know how to control me
I just don't know what I'm supposed to
do here so uh grab the red makeup what
oh I just did that I just did that
why do I need to do it again why am I
still turning around backwards it's not
up there anymore because I grabbed it
since I'm so pro I grabbed it way before
you Oh
we'll give you suspicions for instance
you're a dad and you don't wear makeup
oh all right then let go of it
my suspicion meter is very high what the
hell
oh my suspicion go away after you
complete each room or if you lose how do
I complete this one room okay I gotta
get that book at the journal to end the
er'body got it ha ha Oh
tutorial over man
my mysterious work must be complete
tonight what I wonder suit doll meh
banana okay oh honey I know you've been
working late in the basement but take
tonight off okay I have the most
romantic dinner plan okay honey I'm
going to the store take care of the kids
and do your chores okay oh my oh my oh
my
Octodad is not ready for this okay I see
them the tree trunk that I'm going to
need for the mannequin if I could just
ha ha and I will move you forward whoa
i'm i'm seem to be same
whoa hello not where I whoa controls
have changed somehow these are not the
controls I remember okay why can't I
grab that I'm just touching it ever so
gently with my noodley appendage all
praise is due delete this okay ah hey
look a blueprint
what's my objectives journal 1 Anna from
the kitchen Oh leave that block of wood
there I need a suit from the labor room
octopus doll from the kids room who
alright then alright let's go let's go
but book it right over the train set and
ok oh [ __ ] what if I kids look like oh
hi honey
ok so I gotta take care of the monsters
oh it doesn't look good I wouldn't put
it past if there were actual monsters in
there ok so going through here what am I
looking for in here
oh what's that what is that hi we'll
meet again
octopus what the hell
who is that who the hell is that
no not until you get smarter cuz
obviously you're very dumb if you can't
tell that I am an octopus I mean okay
stop the spiders from reaching your
daughter
what fighters I don't see any spiders
spiders spite oh that spider
ha time to shine yo ha got ya [ __ ] no
one messes with octopus dad's goods ha
got ya oh you think you can mess with me
Oh what ha ha there we go
I go you think you can Oh think you're
gonna be tricky I ah ha got ya man the
things I do for my kids but at least
they love me ok stop the spiders still
more spiders here alright whoa that's a
lot of spiders holy hell huh no God for
my daughter my daughter why are there so
many spiders in my house this is wrong
ah suspicions going high oh boy
no no no no no darling Stacey you still
scared find a story my word oh the
things I do for my children boom what I
love that I'm Laurel
okay I see some on the dresser there my
suspicion is pretty high oh let's see
this one super hug sounds good to me
Connor little girlie I'm going to switch
to feet mode and yes darling I'm going
to switch the feet mode here ah
replacement doll the blue dolphin should
work okay I need to drop that and where
is this so-called blue aha in the chest
oh look at my sweet darling I'm so proud
of you
no no no no she and score her get that
out of the way ha
and highlight it ever so genderly
they're uh up haha not you come on there
we go
got it aha okay okay here we go replace
it so my daughter does not notice the
ink spurting from my arms perfectly fine
alright just ever so gingerly ah aha yes
all the things I'd do for my family
quietly is oh oh quietly quietly ever so
quietly what happens when I get out of
my suit because you got to think that at
night when me and the wifey uh go for a
little romantic interlude we take off
our clothes yeah it sounds strange nope
all right perfectly fine oh hello huh
I'm calling the doorknob okay okay no
carrying on into and out of the room we
are doing good everybody yeah hey oh man
what is my what is this to-do list I
don't care about the to-do list let's
just complete our objective okay what's
in here okay left right left
oh boy where am I now oh my brats son
how about you go screw yourself kid
how was your never born
what up brat I can't wait for sports
Johnson and the football barians
Christmas special Oh what the hell
what is this son I'm going to have a
strongly worded conversation with your
mother about this oh I'm so quick ha ha
yeah wait what I did it I'm going I'm
going the distance I'm going for speed
geez oh it's one way to win all alone in
a total need Oh God
I am not doing so well here cameras not
my Ally whoa whoa whoa the world's going
a little wonky here Wow okay drop I was
drunk again that's probably pretty sad
okay so um score a goal oh I get it
I'm Oh suspicion is going high why the
hell is my door now open what's going on
Oh what the hell okay anyway gonna
ignore that just happened and try to
kick a goal here any better balls
Wow Oh lay crap don't get suspicious son
there's just me warming up ah [ __ ] okay
okay okay all right get ready okay ah
[ __ ] that's like the hardest challenge
I've ever had in a game get the key from
Tommy Tommy Tommy I'm gonna get that key
from you if it's the last thing I do
the last thing I do No thank you thank
you son
go go go boy no go on and play with your
balls as I go over here where the hell
is my so there it is okay it's it why'd
you put it in the grandfather clock yet
Angus gone curd oh uh let me just reach
between my crotch dong oh god oh god oh
god oh god oh god where my suit go oh
what happened to my suit why am I trying
to [ __ ] your wrong way around pass bus
okay
let me drop that and snake my way and
here further oh my god I am stuck I'm
stuck I'm stuck
holy balls okay now try that again
got it and oh whoa what done okay can I
can I whoa hang on there whoa there
partner my suit has somehow gotten stuck
in the wall and holy hell goodness
gracious oh my ah come on it's stuck in
the wall it's like really really stuck
in the wall for some reason I don't know
why but anyway this seems like you're
gonna have place to stop I'm all out of
time in holy crap this is a this is an
interesting game so thank you all so
much for watching um there is a supposed
sequel to the game coming to steam soon
so clicking the link for the to clicking
the link in the description
for this game but be on the lookout for
the next game I was actually someone
responded to my tweet about trying to
find out about this game oh and if you
haven't already follow me on Twitter I
talked with a lot of people there so
thank you all so much for watching click
clean annotations for more videos since
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video bye